R
SARAH? THANK YOU. SO MUCH FOR
COMING IN, ESPECIALLY ON EASTER.
HAPPY EASTER. NOW LET'S SPEAK
WITH CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
KOZIOL CORTEZ OF NEW YORK. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US ON THIS
HOLIDAY SUNDAY. THE ABORTION
PILL RULING DOESN'T TAKE EFFECT
FOR SEVEN DAYS. YOU JUST HEARD
ME DISCUSSING THAT WITH HOW THEY
EVER SARAH, THAT MIGHT BE. THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
APPEALING IT. ARE YOU SATISFIED
WITH WHAT YOU JUST HEARD? AND
WHAT WOULD IT MEAN FOR WOMEN? IF
APPROVAL FOR THIS PILL IS
REVOKED NATIONWIDE? WELL YOU
KNOW, I DO. WHILE I COMMEND THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FOR
APPEALING THE DECISION, AND I
BELIEVE THAT SECRETARY BASADA
HAS BEEN DOING IT AT A
PHENOMENAL JOB IN HIS ROLE. I DO
THINK THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
GAMING OUT WHAT THE VERY REAL
POSSIBILITIES ARE IN THE COMING
DAYS, WEEKS AND MONTHS. THIS IS
NOT JUST ABOUT SPECULATION, BUT
THIS IS ABOUT PREPARATION, AND
THE REALITY OF OUR COURTS RIGHT
NOW IS VERY DISTURBING. THIS
RULING IS IN EXTREME ABUSE OF
POWER. IT IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
EXAMPLE OF JUDICIAL OVERREACH.
THE GROUNDS OF THE RULING ARE
COMPLETELY ARE ARE JUST
COMPLETELY DISCREDITED AND
WITHOUT GROUNDS AND WHAT WE ALSO
LEARNED THIS WEEK IS THAT A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE OF THIS
COURT HAS BEEN RECEIVING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
WORTH OF GIFTS AND EXPENSES AND
HAVING LIFESTYLE SUBSIDIES BY A
BILLIONAIRE WHO HAS BEEN FUNDING
THE SAME TYPES OF JUDICIAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT APPOINTED
THIS JUDGE IN A PARTISAN RULING
IN THE FIRST PLACE. I'M GOING TO
GET TO THAT IN A SECOND, I JUST
WANT TO STICK WITH WITH ABORTION
FIRST. AND THE WHAT? YOU JUST
HEARD ME. ASK THE SECRETARY
ABOUT WAS SOMETHING THAT YOU
CALLED ON THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO DO, WHICH IS
JUST TO SIMPLY IGNORE THE COURT
RULING. THAT'S A PRETTY STANDING
POSITION. IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT
IN THE IN THE ABSTRACT ABOUT THE
NOTION OF JUST IGNORING A
JUDGE'S POSITION, SO MY QUESTION
IS WHEN THIS CASE IS RESOLVED BY
THE SUPREME COURT. SHOULD THE
ADMINISTRATION FOLLOWED THAT
DECISION. IF THAT DECISION ENDS
UP BANNING THIS ABORTION DRUG
WELL, YOU KNOW, I WANT TO TAKE A
STEP BACK AND DIG INTO THE
GROUNDS AROUND IGNORING THIS
PRELIMINARY RULING AS WELL.
THERE IS AN EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT
OF PRECEDENT. FOR THIS. THERE IS
A TERM KNOWN AS AGENCY NON
ACQUIESCENCE, AND THIS HAS BEEN
USED IN FOR FOCUSING. THIS IS A
FIRST THAT THIS IS PRECEDENT
SETTING. IT IS NOT. THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ALSO DID THIS
VERY THING. BUT ALSO IT HAS
HAPPENED BEFORE THE IDEA OF
CONSISTENCY AND GOVERNANCE UNTIL
THERE IS A HIGHER COURT RULING
IS NOT AN UNPRECEDENTED THING TO
HAPPEN. IN FACT, WHEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DID IT, IT WAS
ARGUABLY THROUGH TO A MUCH, YOU
KNOW A VERY GRAVE ISSUE. WHEN IT
CAME TO DHAKA, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WAS ORDERED. TO
FULLY REINSTATE DACA THE DACA
PROGRAM, AND THEY IN IN IN
COMPLETE DEFIANCE, DID NOT DO
THAT THEY RELY ON THE COURTS
RELY ON THE LEGITIMACY OF THEIR
RULINGS AND WHEN THEY MAKE A
MOCKERY OF OUR SYSTEM, A MOCKERY
OF OUR DEMOCRACY AND A MOCKERY
OF OUR LAW AS AS WHAT WE JUST
SAW HAPPEN IN THIS MYTH OF
KRISTEN RULING, THEN I BELIEVE
THAT THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND WE
KNOW THAT THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
HAS AN ENFORCEMENT DISCRETION,
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF A
CONTRADICTING RULING COMING OUT
OF WASHINGTON SHOULD THAT APPLY
IF THE SUPREME COURT UPHELD
UPHOLDS THE TEXAS JUDGE'S
DECISION. YOU KNOW, I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
EXAMINE IS THE GROUNDS OF THAT
RULING. BUT I DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT THE COURTS HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO HAVE THE AUTHORITY
OVER THE FDA THAT THEY JUST
ASSERTED, AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
IT CREATES A CRISIS. SHOULD THE
SUPREME COURT DO THAT? IT WOULD
ESSENTIALLY INSTITUTE NATIONAL
ABORTION BAN BECAUSE YOU HAVE AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF STATES
WHO HAVE IMPLEMENTED SURGICAL'S
SURGICAL BANDS OR BANDS AFTER
VERY EARLY TIME PERIODS. AND
THEN IF YOU PAIR THAT WITH A
MYTHICAL KRISTEN BAN, THEN WE
WILL ESSENTIALLY HAVE A BAN ON
ABORTION. WITH I MEAN, THERE ARE
CERTAIN WORKAROUNDS. I WILL
ADMIT THERE WOULD BE CERTAIN
WORKAROUNDS, BUT WE WOULD HAVE
TAKEN A VERY SIGNIFICANT STEP
TOWARDS A NATIONAL ABORTION BAN
. WHEN ONCE YOU BAN MEDICATION
ABORTION, WHICH REPRESENTS OR
START BANNING MEDICATION
ABORTION, WHICH REPRESENTS THE
OVERWHELMING NUMBER OF ABORTIONS
IN THE UNITED STATES, THEN WE
ARE IN EXTREMELY DANGEROUS
TERRITORY, AND I WOULD URGE THE
SUPREME COURT IN ITS LAWLESSNESS
THAT THEY ARE EXHIBITING RIGHT
NOW. ALREADY THEY'RE
EXTRAORDINARY CONFLICT OF
INTEREST. I MEAN, MY HOPE WOULD
BE THAT WE DO NOT GET TO THAT
POINT. IF WE DO I DO BELIEVE
THAT WE MUST START TO START TO
PUSH BACK ON OUR SYSTEM OF
CHECKS AND BALANCES, WHICH IS
DESIGNED TO PUSH BACK ON SHOULD
THERE BE AN EXAMPLE OF JUDICIAL
TYRANNY AND JUDICIAL OVERREACH?
TALK MORE ABOUT THE SUPREME
COURT AND WHAT YOU MENTION AND
BEFORE, WHICH IS THAT JUSTICE
CLARENCE THOMAS. YOU WANT HIM TO
BE IMPEACHED AFTER A NEW PRO
PUBLIC REPORT THIS WEEK REVEALED
THAT HE ACCEPTED LUXURY
VACATIONS FROM THE REPUBLICAN
BILLIONAIRE DON'T DONOR WITHOUT
DISCLOSING THEM. THOMAS IS NOW
DEFENDING HIMSELF. AND HERE'S
WHAT HE'S SAYING. HE'S SAYING,
QUOTE EARLY IN MY TENURE AT THE
COURT. I SAW GUIDANCE FROM MY
COLLEAGUES AND OTHERS IN THE
JUDICIARY AND WAS ADVISED THAT
THIS SORT OF PERSONAL
HOSPITALITY FROM CLOSE PERSONAL
FRIENDS WHO DID NOT HAVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE COURT WAS
REPORTABLE. WAS NOT REPORTABLE
RATHER. WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE? I
THINK THAT HIS OWN STATEMENT
CONTRADICTS CONTRADICTS MANY OF
THE FACTS ON THE GROUND AND ALSO
RAISES IN OTHER WAYS. EVEN MORE
SERIOUS QUESTIONS LATER ON. IN
HIS STATEMENT, HE STATED THAT
THE REASON AND THE RATIONALE FOR
THIS EXEMPTION WAS PERSONAL
HOSPITALITY FROM AN OLD FRIEND.
AND HE SAID HIMSELF IN HIS
STATEMENT. A FRIEND OF 25 YEARS.
JUSTICE THOMAS HAS BEEN ON THE
COURT FOR 30 YEARS AND SO TO
STAY WHAT HE IS ADMITTING IN HIS
STATEMENT, IN AN ATTEMPT TO
DEFEND HIMSELF IS THAT HE BEGAN
THIS RELATIONSHIP WITH A
BILLIONAIRE AND RECEIVING THESE
SORTS OF GIFTS AS AFTER HE WAS
APPOINTED TO THE SUPREME COURT
OF THE UNITED STATES. I THINK
THAT THAT IN AND OF ITSELF
INDICATES A VERY, VERY SERIOUS
PROBLEM, AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT
HE IS NOW IMPLICATING HIS
COLLEAGUES AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
CHIEF JUSTICE JOHN ROBERTS MUST
NOW COME FORWARD AND STATE IF HE
ALLOWS, AND IS ALLOWING THIS
KIND OF VERY SERIOUS CORRUPTION
TO HAPPEN ON ON THIS COURT. I
THINK YOU KNOW WHEN IT COMES TO
JUSTICE. THOMAS'S STATEMENT WHEN
HE'S TALKING ABOUT HIS
COLLEAGUES, AND WHEN HE'S
TALKING ABOUT WHO ADVISED HIM TO
BREAK THE LAW. I THINK WE NEED
TO KNOW WHO THOSE PEOPLE ARE. TO
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATORS. I MEAN, I BELIEVE
WHAT WE WHAT WE'RE SEEING RIGHT
NOW IS A BREAKING OF THE LAW AND
WE HAVE TO EXAMINE WHAT
INSTITUTIONS I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE CALLS FOR. I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE CALLS FOR CHIEF JUSTICE TO
THE CHIEF JUSTICE. ROBERTS
INITIATED AN INVESTIGATION. I DO
NOT THINK THAT THIS COURT ANY
LONGER HAS THE LEGITIMACY,
ESPECIALLY AFTER THE SUPREME
COURT LEAK LAST YEAR, WHICH
NEVER CAME TO A CONCLUSION
BECAUSE THE INVESTIGATION ITSELF
THAT CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS
STARTED BACK THEN. I BELIEVE IS
VERY DISCREDITED BY NAMING A
POSITION THAT HAS AN INHERENT
CONFLICT OF INTEREST BECAUSE IT
IS EMPLOYED BY THOSE JUSTICES TO
PURSUE THAT INVESTIGATION. I
BELIEVE THAT THE AND IT IS THE
HOUSES RESPONSIBILITY TO PURSUE
THAT INVESTIGATION IN THE FORM
OF IMPEACHMENT. WELL, LET ME ASK
. YOU MEAN YOU, YOU KNOW FULL
WELL THAT THE HOUSE IS NOW RUN
BY REPUBLICANS. HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO MOVE WHAT YOU'RE
CALLING FOR ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT THROUGH A HOUSE THAT
IS RUN BY REPUBLICANS, YOU KNOW
, I THINK IT'S A IT'S A PERFECT
THERE IS THE QUESTION OF THE
POLITICS OF WHAT WE ARE DOING.
AND THERE'S THE QUESTION OF THE
COURSE. AND THE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND THE STRUCTURES OF WHAT WE
ARE DOING. I ADMIT IT IS A IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO SEE A PATH IN
A REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT REFUSES
TO HOLD ITSELF ACCOUNTABLE AND,
IN FACT BREACHES THE LAW ITSELF.
FOR ALL OF THEIR TALK OF A CRIME
WAVE AND DEMOCRATS, REPUBLICANS
TALKING ABOUT CRIME WAVES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. THE CRIME WAVE IS
WITHIN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY. IT
IS WITHIN ALL OF THE WHAT WE ARE
SEEING. WE HAVE WE HAVE SEEN. WE
ARE SEEING BREAKING OF THE LAW
BY CONSERVATIVE MEMBERS OF THE
COURT. WE ARE SEEING A FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
JUST INDICTED IN THE IN RECENT
DAYS. I MEAN, WE NEED TO HOLD
OUR SYSTEMS ACCOUNTABLE AND I DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD BE
REFUSING TO DO THAT. FOR
POLITICAL REASONS. I BELIEVE
THAT WE SHOULD PURSUE THE COURSE
. AND IF IT IS REPUBLICANS THAT
DECIDE TO PROTECT THOSE W